national barbecue month and we are
celebrating this morning but you know
what we're doing we're highlighting a
locally owned restaurant
we're celebrating and we're jealous of
hector mejia you know smoking fires a
business that opened during the tough
darkened periods of the pandemic but
hector is there live this morning near
russell and pecos as it continues to
thrive hector good morning
good morning guys and it's like it's
raining barbecuing here and i just found
out this is a popular celebrity hangout
spot if you don't believe me take a look
right behind me
do you remember that guy alan from i
don't know this famous movie
possibly called a hangover maybe here in
las vegas
and uh you know this place opened here
uh during the pandemic as you just
mentioned john during some really tough
times and it was when they were only
able to offer
a curbside pickup delivery and catering
and now look at the table
it's all full of delicious food joining
aside we have anthony to explain
all right so how are you guys doing
right now we're doing great you know
the community's been really supportive
of what we have going on here
and we have a really good team here and
so i think it's a testament to
how hard we've been working how
dedicated we are to providing a really
quality service and really quality um
product and the huge support from the
community as well
yeah massive support from the community
it's been really awesome just seeing
people from the neighborhood
different parts of the valley coming
here to come try our food all right so
summer means
barbecuing and grilling what do we have
here uh
we have our red white and blue special
here this is for memorial day weekend
this could be 99
it feeds about 10 to 12 people and it's
a ton of food
that's just about you know less than 10
dollars for each person exactly
you guys are also offering a discount
for a memorial day is that right
yeah so for um all active and retired um
veterans we're doing 25
off um and you know we just want to pay
tribute to them for allowing us to do
stuff
such as this and having an amazing
restaurant all right so for those
watching from home and who have never
been here
how do you convince them um what makes
your
barbecue ribs so special um the bbq ribs
are there are san luis style ribs we do
a
house made barbecue sauce they fall off
the bone they're delicious
but the biggest thing i recommend is the
blueberry chicken sliders you can't get
these anywhere else and they're amazing
they are amazing and i i had one myself
and
they're savory spicy and sweet speaking
of recommendations quickly you can
give us some quick advice for those
wanting to do their own barbecue at home
yeah you know just have fun with it
right you know make sure you're
marinating your meats uh make sure
you're
low and slow um make sure you have a
couple beers and drinks cracked open
because making food's supposed to be fun
yeah and your sides you don't want to
forget about your salad right
yeah don't forget about your salad make
sure you get your greens
eat your greens all right well we'll be
posting all the information on our
website 8newsnow.com for now
reporting live hector mejia eighteen's
now back to you guys
please don't eat the table plants please
don't
that is this is the salad yeah
just like this is my spatula for the
barbecue
also i love how armando and hector are
like if we touch everything on this
table we have to take all of
it so they're going to go grab
everything and bring it back yours
but that looks like some tasty stuff
there hector oh my gosh i said the
blueberry was good right it really is